so it's been months since i did our last
sort of comprehensive covet update about
where we are and um sadly
the reason i'm doing such a segment
today is that many signs don't look good
and there's every indication that
another spike could be coming now
there's still
the possibility that that's not the case
and i'll talk about what that looks like
in a moment
but we will get to that um there is a
argument to be made that in general
cases are no longer really the best
indicator of the status of the pandemic
that we should be looking at
hospitalizations and deaths etc and i
think that there's something to that but
still
cases are a leading indicator of
hospitalization and death the question
is just to what degree
now none of us want another spike
but unfortunately it does appear as
though one is coming and there is
evidence from other countries suggesting
this and unfortunately there's also
evidence from the united states and as
always i am always going to report to
you
the way things are
not the way i wish things would be so
first and foremost if we look at global
cases what has been a massive decline
from nearly 4 million cases a day
down well under 2 million cases a day
has reversed now this is global so the
we got down to a lower point
and global cases are now starting to go
up now they're not going up in the
united states yet although i will argue
that they actually are and were
if you look at the right data that you
can see that uh but where are we seeing
actual recorded case numbers increase
well first and foremost germany and
they're not only going up a little bit
uh two days ago
germany had the most
new cases in a single day
of the entire pandemic it it's
exhausting i know it's exhausting
but about 300 000 cases in a single day
in germany
a pandemic record you look at finland
finland since about
mid-january has individually seen some
higher case days and if you look now at
the seven-day rolling average of new
cases in finland
it is at a pandemic high
if you look at the united kingdom
massive decline remember at the peak of
omicron
the uk was seeing about 200 000 known
cases per day about 210 220
that got all the way down below 50k
and now has gone back up by by about
double i mean it's where the uk has
almost now doubled uh daily cases from
that um bottoming out we saw at the
beginning of march that's really not
good because so far in the pandemic
everything that's happened in the uk has
happened in the u.s a little bit later
um and then you look at iceland iceland
which i mean the entire pandemic looks
like almost nothing compared to the
current 2500 cases a day that iceland is
seeing essentially at a pandemic high
seven day average
and um lastly
if you look at uh oh i actually i
actually forget where this is it doesn't
say
i believe that this is
oh where is this this is somewhere in
asia i was trying to give a um
perspective globally i i did not even
include what country this is uh a new
high i think wow i i don't remember
where that is we'll get that information
so
okay cases are going up elsewhere but
they're not going up in the u.s right
well not exactly
in the united states as i've told you
before
waste water covered readings can be a
leading indicator even earlier than
cases about the direction that things
are going
and although dr vincent rackanyello last
time he was on with us said the
wastewater data is not an exact science
it is still a generally speaking leading
indicator and there's an article in
bloomberg
u.s sewer data warns of a new bump in
covid cases after lull
data from wastewater can spot a rise in
infections before it shows up in
positive tests
and unfortunately it's not looking good
more than a third of the cdc's waste
water sample sites across the us
show rising covered trends from march 1
to march 10.
even though cases remain at a record low
the number of sites with rising signals
of covid is nearly twice what it was
during the february 1 to 10 period
it's not clear how many new infections
the signs in the sewage represent and if
if they will turn into a new wave or
will it be just a brief bump on the way
down from the last one so obviously we
all hope
that this is going to be
maybe a leveling out in the united
states and then we continue down or
maybe a slight uptick
the unfortunate thing is if we're
totally honest and transparent if you
look at what's starting to happen in
other countries it doesn't bode
particularly well now everything's wide
open
even though you still have people
protesting mandates and closures in the
united states there essentially are none
everything's open everything's happening
and quite frankly i don't know what
should be taking place right now i i
there is such i mean it's been more than
two years now of this uh almost to the
day it's been two years and a week or
something like that of this at this
point in time
the political will to continue having
things shut down is almost completely
gone
the social motivation to do it is almost
completely gone
the um infection fatality rate is
significantly lower that doesn't mean
that if things get completely out of
control in cases people aren't going to
die they are
um and
i am not in a position where i am going
to say
close everything um it uh we we we now
know that close everything is too broad
a strategy and we know that close
everything in many cases didn't even
really achieve what we wanted it to
achieve
but
do nothing also doesn't make sense if we
see another spike so we're going to be
following the data
um we're going to be tracking what
happens particularly the uk numbers are
not looking good and so far we
everything that happens in the uk
happens here four to six weeks later uh
so my expectation is that by april first
we are going to see higher cases in the
us than we see right now why do i think
that because it's already in the the
wastewater data it's already there
there's no way it would be any other way
the question is is it just a little bump
plateau and then we continue down or not
and i don't know the answer to that
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions to
sleep better their flagship products are
the uhler sleep system and the cube
sleep system which is what i have both
are hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees uh i like the cooler option i
keep mine at 60 degrees and it gives me
a great cool night of sleep no feeling
hot no more sweating i'm falling asleep
faster and it pairs perfectly with chili
sleeps weighted chili blanket which
keeps you cold on top too and for a
limited time chili sleep has a special
offer just for my audience go to
chilisleep.com
pacman to learn about the exclusive
discount the link is down below